you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video so I
guess it's a little bit different
because you can actually see me if
you're new here as in past 300,000
subscribers which isn't really that new
but anyway then you wouldn't have seen
me before it was the first time that you
would have seen me so hello all of you
guys so you know this video is going to
be unscripted so it's not going to be
the clearest of videos but let me just
let me just say a few things so what I
want to say is really the first of all
thank you guys thank you all of you for
helping me pass 1 million subscribers
never really thought I'd be in this
position and you know I'm just really
grateful to be able to actually do this
kind of thing and have the opportunity
and the experience of all of this really
what else do I want to say I'd like to
also point out that I guess for me
anyway in my mind this is this is the
base level this is level 1 or stage 1 of
this channel I want to really do better
I have basically a lot of interests of
Science and Technology are just a couple
of them so you know what I'll start
there and obviously have an engineering
degree as well that helps that I think
really to increase the capability and
capacity of this channel there must be
more people on board so I'm looking at
hiring some other researchers to help
with research topics and things like
that and also some script writers and
perhaps another editor and also some
animators so with this I hope to be able
to put out videos more frequently but
obviously finding the right people and
all this is going to take a lot of time
but I just thought I might as well let
you guys know since we're just sitting
down and having a little bit of a
conversation what else I want to say
actually yeah I was on Australian
television on the nightly news bulletin
on channel 9 if you guys know that if
you're from Australia so if you guys
want to see that I've actually got a
YouTube a YouTube secret link basically
and I'll put that in the description
and it was interesting it was an
interesting bulletin I get to get to see
me in a different light but yeah it's
just basically about YouTube and what
people are doing in Perth in YouTube and
it was featuring me I guess that was
pretty cool
to be part of what else yeah I've been
getting some comments more frequently
about the channel name so if you go back
to my older videos you would see that it
was called Huston start with the T so
the channel name was actually cold
fusion because I chose that to be the
channel name because cold fusion was
originally taken so I got you know the
impression that the channel wasn't
really taking off back in the day
because people weren't typing it in
right or spelling it wrong the one
remembering it and so eventually I got
rid of the T when YouTube allowed
multiple channel names to have the same
name so when I did that at the time of
channel started taking off which is
great but yeah still getting comments
from all the videos saying you saw the
channel name wrong I got a very lengthy
email actually this morning about that
but um yeah so that's just to clear that
up I know most of you don't care but
just for those who are wondering also
I've been writing some music again I do
have another track hopefully coming out
soon it's probably about 80% done I
think that's pretty much it
sorry for the you know messiness of this
video I'm just kind of just talking
whatever but yeah you know thank you
guys once again and really there'll be
more to come
there's definitely go any more on this
channel some interesting topics that I'm
thinking of so I guess I'll see you guys
again for the next video until next time
enjoy yourselves and have a good one
Cheers
[Music]
you